sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans une europe /
sensation en association avec tv 78 une
émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg voici une
sélection des meilleurs moments de
l'émission
zone robe l'europe dans ma région
jean monnet est l'un des pères
fondateurs de l'europe je me trouve
aujourd'hui à bazoches sur guyonne dans
les yvelines devant ce qui est à
l'époque sa résidence principale il a
vécu ici pendant près de trente ans
jusqu'à son décès on a rendez vous avec
deborah qui va nous faire une petite
visite
[Musique]
bonjour deborah bonjour alors expliquez
nous un peu où est-ce qu'on est
actuellement aujourd'hui vous êtes à la
maison jean monnet à bazoches sur
guyonne dans les yvelines donc c'est ici
qu'ils jamonais avec lui de 1945 jusqu'à
sa mort en 1979 on passe à la visite
bien sûr si
donc nous sommes ici de le salon de la
maison jean monnet
pour commencer cette visite je vous je
vais vous parler de la déclaration
schuman donc c'est ici que cette
déclaration a été écrite dont ces salons
même par jean monnet et ses
collaborateurs de l'éminent 1950 et donc
c'est à travers cette déclaration qui a
été donné le coup d'envoi à la première
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier très important et 7,7 cette
feuille de synthèse où on pouvoir
le déséquilibre militaire à faveur d'ela
de la deûle à l'allemagne nazie on
pouvoir à travers
avec un coup d'oeil effectivement la
supériorité militaire
en armement allemande donc à travers ce
feuilles de synthèse on pose par et qui
est montrée par jean monnet à au
président des états unis et roosevelt
qui convainc
roosevelt et les états unis à rentrer en
guerre donc à côté des alliés
et enfin nous trouvons ici de la chambre
du couple 1
ici c'est une pièce
beaucoup plus anti main on voit des des
photos familiales donc on voit jean
monnet avec sa fille marianne on voit
jamais ni avec robert schumann avec
konrad adenauer le chancelier allemand
on voit également un portrait de jean
monnet pas par sa femme simone et ça y
est la visite est terminée maintenant
place à un petit concert c'est le groupe
baroque nomade qui nous fait le plaisir
de jouer pour nous aujourd'hui ici dans
les jardins du père fondateur près d'un
hectare de terrain
[Musique]
sonos robe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui ian christophe eu
jane eurodéputés allemands membres du
groupe renault europe vice président de
la commission des transports et du
tourisme
bonjour bonjour alors la chancelière
allemande angela merkel s'apprête à
quitter ses fonctions est là elle est
resté seize ans au pouvoir elle a
traversé différentes crises elle a connu
beaucoup de présidents de la république
qu'ils soient français ou plutôt
américain bon pas forcément en russie
qu'est ce que vous retenez de ses 16 ans
de pouvoir dans gala merkel c'est
surtout la stabilité
l'allemagne en europe a été un point
d'ancrage pour beaucoup de pays et le
rôle du chancelier allemand ou de la
chancelière dans ce cas est toujours de
faire le paon vers les pays de l'est
comme nous en allemagne en a un passé
des deux côtés donc ça c'était un rôle
important de angela merkel et je pense
que là elle a bien eu ce rôle est là
elle était dans ce sens une bonne chance
faire alors son bilan reste quand même
contraste est plutôt en manière en
matière d'écologie elle laisse un pays à
la pointe de la technologie de
d'écologie dans la vie du quotidien mais
par contre les mines de charbon par
exemple dont on parle souvent en ce
moment continue de polluer c'est un peu
paradoxal l'allemagne et la fin du
nucléaire c'est pour fin 2022 mais
parallèlement parallèlement faut
compenser avec ses centrales à charbon
on explique souvent que l'allemagne à
arrêter le nucléaire mais continuent
d'acheter de l'énergie nucléaire dans
les pays partenaires étrangers dont la
france est ce que c'est une vraie bonne
décision au niveau écologique
bah c'est une situation ambiguë mais le
nucléaire c'est dans la société
allemande c'est une question où il y en
a pas il n'y a pas de la vie
avec le trauma de tchernobyl qui a bien
eu lieu et où là le nuage est arrivé en
allemagne
en
il ya une une forte cohérence dans la
société allemande de sortir du nucléaire
et ont misé sur les énergies renouvables
c'est pas facile parce que il n'ya pas
personne qui est pas tout le monde qui
est heureux d'avoir des éoliennes près
de chez soi mais
on essaye par contre c'est un défi pour
la stabilité du réseau du réseau
électrique et on a encore beaucoup de
progrès à faire dans le futur pour
vraiment remplacer
l'énergie des centrales nucléaires parce
que on va aussi sortir du charbon il ya
un plan pour ça déjà à voter au niveau
national en allemagne et
la sortie du charbon ce sera le prochain
grand projet au niveau
électrique alors vous le disiez angela
merkel a globalement bénéficié d'une
très bonne popularité au sein de
l'allemagne et pourtant le magazine
américain time avait titré pourquoi tout
le monde aime détester en gala merkel
elle ne faisait pas vraiment l'unanimité
au niveau international cette fois-ci
déjà en allemagne est le plus et pas
d'unanimité 1 parce que elle était quand
même
une
une femme politique conservatrice donc
les grandes réformes du pays et on en a
besoin et ne les a pas entamé donc
c'était c'était un sujet clé aussi à la
fin de son mandat et c'est pour ça que
maintenant il ya beaucoup de
d'espoir qui est des réformes qui vont
débuter et on est dans la seine sur la
scène internationale
avec la décision sur la migration en
2015 2016
c'était un moment clé où on était pour
ou contre cette décision et c'était une
décision de triqueti vente et je pense
pour ça il ya beaucoup qui détestent
aguila merkel sur la scène
internationale mais d'ailleurs vous
parler de cette décision cette décision
a amené l'extrême droite à faire son
retour au parlement à la suite de cette
décision de la première fois que notre
parlement en 2017 est ce que ça montre
une vraie scission dans le peuple
allemand comme on le voit ailleurs en
france en italie un nationalisme qui
prend qui prend de l'ampleur finalement
la
l'extrême droite en allemagne est
quelque chose de nouveau ce phénomène
c'est apparu beaucoup plus tard que dans
nos pays européens et ça a émergé
d'abord avec du
criticisme contre la politique fiscale
européenne ça c'est le débit de but de
l'extrême droite en allemagne et après
il y avait cette décision pour
concernant la crise en syrie et
l'accueil des migrants qui a fait
grandir l'extrême droite mais il reste à
10% ils ont reculé avec les élections
qui ont lieu le 26 septembre donc je
pense qu'il n'y a pas de vraie scission
en allemagne ces élections qui ont eu
lieu en septembre ont montré que ces le
les partis du centre du centre droit et
du centre gauche et du centre centre qui
ont eu du succès et c'est les extrêmes
qui ont reculé donc je pense pas qu'il
ya une vraie scission dans la société
allemande alors vous parliez de migrants
l'une des crises majeures actuelle c'est
le retour au pouvoir des talibans en
afghanistan
quelle position doit adopter l'europe
selon vous est faut-il reconnaître le
gouvernement taliban
il faut pas reconnaître le gouvernement
taliban mais néanmoins il faut trouver
des solutions pour les gens qui sont
affectés il ya énormément de réfugiés
qui ont besoin d'une aide qui fuit
système où on n'a pas le droit de dire
ce qu'on pense où on n'a même pas le
droit de jouer de la musique donc où les
femmes n'ont pas de nom pas leurs
propres droits donc je pense qu'il faut
aider dans une situation comme ça
d'abord les pays voisins de
l'afghanistan qui accueille actuellement
des migrants et aussi pour un
plan
d'accueillir des réfugiés qui on
travaille avec nous en afghanistan qui
on travaille avec la france avec
l'allemagne avec d'autres gros dos avec
l'europe qui ont travaillé avec nous
pour installer la démocratie la
pluralité et qui ont essayé de faire
émerger nos valeurs qui sont en danger
maintenant et je pense qu'on a une
responsabilité accueillir et six
personnes là parce qu'ils vont pas
pouvoir retourner dans leur pays tant
que les talibans sont au pouvoir alors
on parle de relations franco allemandes
souvent à la tête de l'europe le moteur
franco-allemand on entend souvent ce
terme alors en gala merkel c'est bientôt
fini le rôle de leader de l'europe c'est
un rôle que emmanuel macron aimerait
bien endosser est-ce que vous pensez que
il a suffisamment d'envergure pour
endosser ce costume mais il est le
leader en europe actuellement parce que
l'allemagne sous merkel était incapable
à répondre et à collaborer avec lui à la
même hauteur
rappelez vous
son discours à la sorbonne et la réponse
tardive de l'allemagne c'est une
occasion manquée on aura maintenant la
seule de la situation qu'on aura un
nouveau gouvernement en allemagne on
aura les élections présidentielles
l'année prochaine en france il ya un
nouveau tandem qui va ce qui va se créer
j'espère que à l'issue de ce tandem il
ya beaucoup d'énergie pour pour l'europe
parce qu'il faut faire bouger les choses
pour que l'europe soit pas que dans les
têtes des gens mais aussi haut que dans
les coeurs des gens parce que on doit
amener des solutions à des problèmes qui
sont qui sur la qui sont présents et
actuellement on est trop lent dans les
processus de décision en europe 1 vous
parlez de l'élection présidentielle en
france en 2022 est ce que les allemands
se montrent attentifs à ce qui se passe
en france en ce qu'il va se passer en
france parce qu'il faut le rappeler
aussi que la france prendra la
présidence tournante du conseil de
l'union européenne à partir du 1er
janvier 2022 oui c'est une situation un
moment clé pour l'europe parce que la
france en tant que grand pays de
l'europe elle a une responsabilité de
faire avancer des dossiers et en
allemagne le notre agenda c'est d'avoir
un nouveau gouvernement
avant noël
et j'espère que ça va se passer comme ça
donc je pense je pense que ce sera un
bon moment pour relancer une dynamique
dans des sous dans des dossiers clés en
europe et on n'attend pas on est prête à
travailler avec le gouvernement français
et on espère bien que ça sera
le même gouvernement et avant et après
les élections vous pensez que le peuple
allemand est très attaché peut-être à
emmanuel macron et ses idées on
reconnaît quand même que emmanuel macron
il a des idées pro européenne et il ya
une large majorité en allemagne qui
soutient cette idée pro européenne
et vous pensez que le père de l'enfant a
peur que marine le pen ou eric zemmour
qui n'a actuellement pas encore
officiellement candidat on en saura
peut-être d'ici quelques semaines vous
pensez que le peuple allemand a peur que
marine le pen arrive au pouvoir en
france je pense que toute l'europe a
peur que ça arrive et on souhaite au
peuple français de plus ça n'arrive pas
parce que ça serait une situation
dramatique pour l'union européenne
tant que oui il ya une peur comme ça
mais c'est une peur qui qu' il y à
beaucoup d'autres pays également
regarder la situation pologne regarder
la situation en hongrie
c'est c'est quelque chose où on doit
être très attentif et ferme en même
temps parce qu'on ne peut pas accepter
que en europe des des droits
fondamentaux sont bafoués et l'europe
doit être très fort vis-à-vis s'est
défini très bien merci beaucoup et jan
christoph heusgen d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
allemands membres du groupe renault en
europe et vice président de la
commission des transports et du tourisme
saône robe l'invité politique
le 15 août dernier en seulement quelques
heures kaboul tombée aux mains des
talibans 20 ans après avoir été chassé
du pouvoir les talibans ont repris le
contrôle de l'afghanistan
quel avenir pour les femmes dans ces
conditions aujourd'hui je reçois
l'eurodéputé belge à sita coco bonjour
brunch ou alors vous êtes membre de la
commission des libertés civiles de la
justice et des affaires intérieures et
membre de la sous-commission des droits
de l'homme tout d'abord votre sentiment
sur cette prise de pouvoir des talibans
l'afghanistan c'était un combat
peut-être déjà perdu d'avancé pour les
forces internationales dès leur arrivée
je ne crois pas que c'était un combat
perdu d'avancé
mais aujourd'hui on se rend bien compte
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs et quand
on regarde la façon dont l'ancien
président donc fin le président afghan
s'est enfui en abandonnant son pays et
son peuple ensemble et apparemment avec
beaucoup d'argent on se rend compte que
la communauté internationale a beaucoup
sponsoriser la corruption qu'il n'y a
pas eu qu'ils aient eu beaucoup
d'assistanat et qu'il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de renforcement de la capacité
au niveau local donc je dis moi je suis
très inquiète pour la situation des
femmes et des filles mais une fois de
plus on peut je voudrais parler d'une
phrase qu'a dit une journaliste de cnn
et madame howard qui a dit que quand il
ya eu les attentats du 11 septembre elle
était assise quelque part et elle s'est
dit j'ai honte je n'ai pas fait
attention à ce qui se passait dans le
monde j'ai l'impression que tous les
jours on répète la même aujourd'hui on
apprend de parler de l'afghanistan
on a oublié ce qui s'est passé les
années écoulées
mais est ce qu on se rend bien compte de
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
pas seulement à nathalie st moïse mais
aussi ailleurs pour les mêmes raisons et
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un échec
militaire mais surtout d'un échec
politique finalement c'est un échec
stratégique c'est un échec au niveau de
tout ce qui est politique internationale
et diplomatie ça devrait vraiment rentré
dans les cas d'école pour les tous les
étudiants en sciences politiques ou en
diplomatie je pense que on persiste
également dans l'erreur et le dindon de
la farce un peu c'est l'union européenne
qui n'a même pas réussi à trouver sa
place dans cette conversation dans ce
dialogue alors que là il y aura eu aucun
rôle finalement dans ce processus de
paix qui a essayé d'être engagé avec les
talibans mais c'est justement vous le
dit bien le pen n'a eu aucun rôle en
fait on est passif on attend d'avoir
alors qu'on a quelque chose à dire donc
moi j'ai fait ça on a aidé on à aider
l'afghanistan on n'aide en a beaucoup on
a beaucoup un budget prévu pour ça on a
encore entendu la prison de la
commission didier qu'on allait augmenter
son budget sera donc aujourd'hui il faut
évidemment se concentrer sur les femmes
et les filles les gens qui défendent les
droits humains en afghanistan mais sans
légitimer les talibans sans renforcer
leur pouvoir et celle là là c'est
vraiment assez difficile à faire et on
aura besoin de réponses au cours des
semaines qui viennent c'est la façon
dont la commission va procéder pour
acheminer l'aide et c'est la façon dont
va procéder pour se faire respecter et
faire respecter les droits humains et
aussi au niveau de l'immigration on va
évidemment devoir accueillir les gens il
faut aider les gens il faut les
accueillir mais il faut également
construire au niveau de la région on ne
peut pas dire que voilà tout ce qu'ils
doivent s'enfuir l'afghanistan aux prix
ils vont venir en europe c'est toujours
la même philosophie ce n'est pas si
facile et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
possible non plus on a la même situation
au sahel donc la france aura bientôt
peut-être un autre afghanistan dans ce
qui se passe au sahel dans la région
ouest africaine alors vous vous le
disiez avec les talibans l'une des liens
d inquiétude c'est la place des femmes
dans le pays leur condition s'améliorer
petit à petit mais elle restait quand
même très précaires et quelles sont vos
craintes est ce que vous pensez à un
retour de la charia on pense qu'on pense
au fait que quand j'ai les taliban
étaient au pouvoir à l'époque la burqa
était obligatoire par exemple est ce que
c'est c'est l'une de vos craintes oui
j'ai beaucoup de craintes mais aussi un
peu d'espoir un peu d'espoir parce que
venant moi même d'une une culture très
près à patriarcal traits assez
traditionnel où il y avait quand même l'
influence de la région islamique aussi
je crois que il y a un effet sur les
petites filles quand elles voient la
liberté la première fois que je vis une
femme libre cela m'a fait quelque chose
et après on peut plus vous enlever ça de
la tête mais après il faut tout un
chemin pour arriver à conquérir cette
liberté dont les femmes afghanes ou
encore tout un chemin à parcourir et là
on les abandonne un peu dans leur élan
et ça c'est vraiment dommage c'est très
inquiétant les talibans promettent monts
et merveilles on sait très bien que
c'est des relations publiques et qui
n'ont pas du tout l'intention c'est
impossible leur idéologie est basé sur
la domination de la femme elle doit
rester au foyer et mettre au monde
surtout des garçons est elle-même en
soit elle n'est rien d'autre qu'un
utérus et et un buffet qui leur faire
manger c'est tout et donc aujourd'hui ça
ne va pas changer quel que soit ce qu'il
dit ce dont il faut qu'on reste vigilant
mais corps est vigilant aussi par
rapport à l'islamisme radical isme
islamique aussi en europe c'est j'ai vu
à la ville est ce que vous pensez qu'il
ya beaucoup de soutien à ce qui se passe
en afghanistan en europe il n'y a je
n'ai pas encore vu les gens qui
soutenaient vraiment ouvertement les
talibans mais nous étions au danemark
pour la conférence pour les droits de
l'homme et il y avait une collègue
député qui a pris un taxi et le
chauffeur du taxi était quelqu'un qui
lui disait à quel point les talibans
était formidable elle nous l'a raconté
on a eu un peu la chair de poule parce
que c'est quand même inquiétant mais
aujourd'hui c'est que les talibans
défendent cet islamisme radical il
existe également en europe et il ya des
gens qui le soutiennent mais quand on
voit les talibans qui font ce qu'ils
font tout le monde dit oui mais il faut
il faut arrêter ça c'est inacceptable
on voit une petite fille qui soutient à
l'aéroport en belgique on dit c'est
génial c'est le symbole de la liberté
très bien mais je tiens à souligner que
les gens qui sont en tout dix ans
enthousiaste et je suis d'accord avec
vous il faut être enthousiaste quand on
voit une petite fille sautier parce
qu'elle est libre ils doivent aussi les
autres jours défendre les petites filles
des quartiers ici qui elles souffrent au
quotidien sous le poids de l'islamisme
dans les quartiers mais alors là on dit
mais c'est leur culture laissez les
faire alors ça c'est dangereux il faut
il faut être
cohérent quand l'italie scandé quand les
taliban étaient au pouvoir en
afghanistan entre 96 et 2001 des femmes
étaient exécutés sur la place publique
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
malheureusement quelque chose qui
pourrait revenir malgré le fait qu'ils
disent qu'ils ont changé qu'ils sont
ouverts notamment à l'éducation par
exemple je ne peux pas lire dans
l'avenir mais si j'étais aussi ici en
tant que femme je n'aimerais vraiment
pas être en afghanistan ça c'est très
évident si j'étais une personne
homosexuelle
je voudrais pas non plus être en
afghanistan si j'ai une petite fille qui
doit encore grandir le doute qui
voudrait pas non plus je crois qu'il n'y
a rien dans ce qu'ils promettent dans ce
qu ils sont denses qui ne ils ont
démontré jusque là qui permet d'imaginer
que ce sera le paradis pour les femmes
en tout cas pour l'instant ce n'est pas
le cas donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on
soit vigilant et qu'on ne faut pas être
naïf si on imagine on laisse les
talibans nous bercer avec leurs belles
chansons en disant qu'ils vont donner la
liberté aux femmes
ça va mal se passer je crois qu'il faut
rester vigilant à rester ferme tout en
gardant un lien avec la société civile
et les activistes qui défendent les
droits des femmes c'est important avec
cette situation en afghanistan vous le
disiez il se pose la question des
réfugiés quelle est la place de l'europe
dans l'extradition de ces réfugiés est
ce qu'il aurait fallu s'y prendre plus
en amont pour évacuer des gens oui est
ce que il n'est pas trop tard finalement
et est-ce qu'il aurait pas fallu une
réponse à l'échelle européenne je pense
qu'il est totale pour beaucoup de choses
et pas seulement pour ceux ci je crois
que il fallait agir en amont pa se passe
pas seulement quand le président bart
hayden a commencé à dire qu'il fallait
qu'il allait quitter l'afghanistan il a
il a évoqué les trois cent mille soldats
formés que face à 75000
sondant talibans mais
c'était c'était évident c'était évident
que ça allait mal se passer et que
kaboul allait tomber et donc on a été en
retard leur nourriture on aurait dû et
c'est toujours comme ça on attend
toujours le dernier moment et même là il
ne s'est imposé qu'à nous la réaction
est alors effectué les européens les
américains simplement nous en priorité
au dernier moment et on s'est dit bon on
évacuera ce qui reste dans le ski reste
comme place on aurait dû évacuer les
gens beaucoup plus tôt et des personnes
qui habitent ici n'aurait pas dû aller
en vacances en afghanistan malgré les
conseils du ministère des affaires
étrangères donc il fallait respecter
cela je crois que quand ben laden est
venu tout le monde a été ébloui par son
discours à l'otan par tous les jolis
mots et par le fait qu'il n'ait pas trop
mais en réalité on n'a pas vu notre
propre rôle et la réaction que l'union
européenne devait avoir par rapport à ça
je trouve que c'est c'est vraiment
moi j'ai honte quand je vois comment
nous avons réagi de manière passive et
on est toujours en train de courir
derrière les faits c'est une politique
du retard et c'est dommage et les
talibans on voit ça aujourd'hui ils ne
vont pas vous avez demandé s'ils
allaient discuter les femmes en public
moi je pense qu'ils sont à une autre
étape où ils vont aller de manière
beaucoup plus subtil que cela donc
aujourd'hui en privant de légende
éducation par exemple ça c'est une façon
d'exécuter une femme parce qu'on lui
enlève tous les moyens on allait tous en
france voilà tout son potentiel et elle
a goûté à ce que c'est que cette liberté
là et elle la veut plus qu'avant et dont
il faut qu'on nourrissent un peu ce
pouvoir là je crois que c'est peut-être
un écrivain français qui avait dit que
pour pour construire un bateau il faut
pas rassemblé ses hommes et ses femmes
et leur donner des matériels des données
désordre il faut leur donner le désir
profond de la mer et j'espère que le
désir de la liberté est là et que la
graine est aimé et qu'elle va continuer
à pousser nous on devra condé va aider à
la rose est alors un autre problème qui
se pose c'est que la turquie est à la
frontière de tous et de tous ces
conflits la turquie accueille déjà trois
millions et demi de réfugiés syriens la
turquie est en train de construire un
mur à sa frontière avec l'iran pour
empêcher l'afflux de migrants afghans
ankara se trouve une nouvelle fois la
garde frontières de l'europe comment
est-ce que l'union européenne va encore
gérer une nouvelle crise va s'ouvrir à
la turquie c'est encore aller chercher à
gérer les conséquences de l'inaction
alors que si on avait agi en amour on ne
serait pas dans cette situation et ça ne
concerne pas que l'afghanistan c'est
aussi ce qui se passe hier encore il ya
eu un bateau qui a dû être secourues au
large de lampedusa avec plus de 700
réfugiés à bord migrants à bord et donc
on assiste à une répétition les choses
et la turquie va continuer à mener sa
position et et 7 cette absence de
politique migratoire et l'union
européenne va continuer à se laisser
avoir et il n'ya pas que la turquie
aujourd'hui on doit également faire face
à l'attitude de la chine et du pakistan
qui joue double jeu avec avec les
talibans donc on risque de se retrouver
dans une situation où on n'a rien à dire
on va simplement subir et courir après
les faits et celle et des conséquences
et subir d'autres chantage de la part de
d'erdogan au dessous de son remplaçant
ou alors on va se faire avoir quand il y
aura quelqu'un d'autre qui remplacera
erdogan et qui sera peut-être moins
brutale apparemment on va faire comme on
a fait avec button et trump en disant oh
mais il est tout gentil le président
américain moi je dis pas qu'il est
méchant mais il défend son pays il
défend son pays et c'est le rôle c'est
le rôle des dirigeants politiques ce que
nous devons faire c'est défendre l'euro
merci beaucoup à ckac encore d'avoir été
avec nous dans une europe / sensations
je le rappelle vous êtes vice présidente
du groupe des conservateurs et
réformistes européens et puis vous êtes
membre de la commission des libertés
civiles de la justice et des affaires
intérieures et membre de la
sous-commission des droits de l'homme
sous drop
zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de strasbourg vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine très bonne soirée
sonne robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france